here are three helpful essay writing
tips from conmigo
plan and outline
before you start writing brainstorm and
organize your thoughts together also
make an outline that includes your main
points and supporting evidence
write a strong thesis statement
your thesis statement is the main
argument of your essay make sure the
specific debatable and focus also be
sure to include it in your intro as it
will guide the ideas and content in your
body paragraphs
use clear and concise language support
your ideas with specific evidence and
examples be sure to avoid words that are
vague unnecessary and complex
check out Khan Mikko for more tips